this is terrible going from a really
cool talk to something that's very
nuts-and-bolts so what I wanted to share
in this session was some of the things
that I look for when I'm having to code
optimize we we have a consulting team in
the UK office and one of the things we
get to fail often is here's piece of
code would make it better make it need
to make it faster and so this is almost
my sort of checklist for where I start
because in general the Wolfram language
is capable of great speed and it's
capable of great cleverness and it's
capable of great accuracy but not all at
the same time and so very often it's
about compromises and choices you make
and I want to walk you through some of
those choices so if there's a meta point
one of the top on the list is you're
doing things more cleverly than you
thought you were or you intended to or
you needed to and my number one that I
go straight for is an example of that so
if I just run these two almost identical
examples here and you'll see a lot of
these uses of absolute timing you can
see the first example takes well over a
second and the second example is four
thousandths of a second big difference
and yet the answer we get out is
identical the key thing here is as most
of you all know there's a difference in
number types we have high precision
exact and machine precision numbers if
you care about speed machine precision
numbers as soon as you can and all the
way through consistently so you're
giving up some of the accuracy and
you'll see why this one's so slow if I
show you the the answer without
numerical izing at the end you'll see
that the answer is extremely accurate
this is a fraction I think yes there's
the you might and the denominator coming
out to a very small number as a whole
but you have to create this accurate
thing before you then get the
approximate one if you want the
approximate just go straight there
likewise here's a another simple example
I will show you the download for all of
these if you want to get them at the end
but again it's exactly the same problem
one I start with two and I iterate some
function the other one I start with
two-point so just get those decimal
points in at every number at an early
opportunity and here we again we're
getting an equally huge difference and
if you look
it's the reason the intermediate value
on this one is this horribly large
symbolic expression that can't even be
displayed it's too big now indirectly
we're using a special datatype and I
know this goes against the the kind of
Wolfram language message that you
shouldn't care about internals and
everything should be automated for you
but for getting the very best out of it
you need to know a little bit about in
Turtles and there are several special
datatypes the most important in terms of
its wide use is the packed array and
here's an example I'm going to make some
random numbers here's a million random
numbers and I'll show you how much
memory it takes it takes eight megabytes
to hold that make sure Vandor numbers
and then I'm going to make it a million
in one numbers I'm just going to stick
an extra one on the end but something
really dramatic happens here because
there's a whole bunch of commands in
Mathematica that try and figure out if
there's some commonality of the dates
from the packed array is the mechanism
for this so the round and real function
knows in advance of all its numbers are
going to be real and so the way
internally that's held is we have a data
object that says following us some reals
number number number number the general
Mathematica data structure has to say
here's an element which is a real in its
number as this here's an element which
is a real and it's number is this yes
and it takes a lot more data to hold
that so things like table and random
real and all kinds of these functions
anything that where the argument is
predictable have a tendency to go
straight into this packed array and the
and if you mix data types then you break
that and it has to immediately put in
all this extra information and it's data
size corresponds to performance time so
generally doing something on this
version of data is going to be three
times slower than the other at best now
there are some low-level commands on
this I can ask if things are packed
arrays and you can see the key
difference here is that this internal
flag is different and I can force it
into a pack so rail set array so I can
repair that second version like by
forcing its wheels and then forcing it
to simplify itself and we go back down
to the small size but generally if you
follow the rule of numerical numbers
from the beginning then you should find
packed arrays happen fairly
naturally I'm not gonna go through all
the examples because I have a short to
slaughter talking here so sparse array
is another key one less generally
applicable but if you've got a dataset
where most of the numbers are zero then
new sparse array almost the numbers are
the same I should say that sparse array
is much more compact and there's this
weird really there for us structured
array which is for particular things
like upper triangular matrices which if
you happen to be in a very niche area it
can be useful but one that is more
useful is the file format that the MX
file format if you want to write things
to disk and read them back out of
Mathematica then nothing beats dumps a
for performance it's almost like a war
memory damp
there's no conversion into CSV format
and they're having to convert it back
again so you can just push the memory
out and back in again and this is really
really fast to dump large amounts of
memory large amounts of data to disk but
it's platform-specific so you can't move
that file between Macs and windows or
even between windows 32-bit and windows
64 so it's got its limitations but be
aware of these and if you can use them
use them okay now this is the one that's
fairly fiddly but if you care about
performance you need to know about and
that's the the internal and external
compilation of Mathematica and you can
see the codes getting a bit more
complicated here but only because I've
got a silly example that's doing lots of
low-level operations so I'm I'm starting
with some values and then I've got some
do loops that does some addition and
multiplication and I'll say more about
trying to avoid low-level code in a
minute but if you're forced into
low-level code or we should be running
this because it's slow then you
definitely need to start thinking about
compiling the operation and what you're
doing with compile you'll see the code
below is almost identical except I sort
the word function for the word compile
is you're making an assumption about the
data type so you're throwing away the
flexibility of this X could be complex
or could be integer it could be symbolic
you're saying it has to be real or and
you can say some other things like it
has to be integer or it has to be rank
two matrix of wheels but it's fairly
limited as a type mechanism but why be
able to make those upfront assumptions
we get 30 times faster performance for
exactly the same code there are some
tweaks as well you can go further that
when you start applying some
intelligence there's a few attributes
that you can give that says I know that
these operations on a list are
independent so I don't have to worry
about side effects I can do these things
on every element separately and that
speeds things up and I know that they're
completely independent so I can do them
in parallel I don't have to wait till
the first one's done before I can do the
second and between those two
improvements I get a little bit more
improvement performance so we've gone
down now to 100 times faster than the
original but I'm still within
Mathematica so this is compiled into a
Mathematica pseudo machine and behind
the scenes this is some of the magic
that I mentioned later that compile gets
called automatically so sometimes there
are there are hidden things going on
that make things faster automatically
and then finally if you really care
about speed then there's an extra option
on this last version which just adds
this option here and that triggers are
more complicated chain of operations so
it will take the code it'll make the
pseudo compiled version in Mathematica
it'll then call a conversion program to
turn that into C code it will then pass
that to a c compiler to compile it it'll
make an executable which will then use
library link to connect back in and
attach to this symbol C F to C so
there's a lot going on using the
machinery of Mathematica but all have to
do is had the option and now I get C
level performance but still able to use
sort of Mathematica syntax and and
joining up the bits of of Mathematica
now not everything is compiled of all
the subsets fairly limited at the moment
to mostly procedural programming and
arithmetic I type operators but they
tend to be the kinds of things that you
are writing low-level code where you get
the biggest difference between
Mathematica and low-level compiled
languages I believe there is a project
to really expand the scope of compiled
so it's worth investing some time
learning about this because it will get
better over future versions as well but
it's it's already a low-level code is
the solution you want to aim for
so I said trying to avoid low-level
functions here's a general tip that I
think serves well throughout that
is do not reinvent the wheel not just
because it it's an effort for you but
you can really that may be an
exaggeration but typically if you tree
and find re-implement something that's
built into Mathematica the Mathematica
version will be faster and even for
little details of the operation if you
can do things in one Mathematica command
it's there too that's generally a good
thing partly because some of these
things are implemented in C rather than
in top level code and and so you get
those kind of performance improvements
of running into native C partly because
we have lots of clever people thinking
about clever algorithms that if you're
well studied you might know but a naive
implementation will never catch up so
even poorly written C code is slower
than then well written Mathematica
because of doing things the right way
matters much more than often than the
language that it's written in so he's a
subtle example I've got a list of a
million matrices that all 2x2 and I want
to turn them into a list of four element
lists so the way I would naturally
program this is I would say map flatten
down that list of matrices so flatten
each matrix out in turn and it's not bad
point two seconds
flatten though if you actually read all
the detailed documentation on it has all
kinds of options about whether I'm
flattening level 1 & 2 together or 2 & 3
together so I can actually do the whole
operation in one command instead of two
and because it's all been built into
flatten to know how to handle all kinds
of different level specifications the
whole thing happens in within the
flatten and there's no kind of loop of
map going over the things returning
values and having to assemble them
afterwards and you get exactly the same
result much much faster and likewise of
course there's lots of mathematical
things so don't go trying to implement
basic mathematics if if they're built in
us let's skip that one
okay so there's a general thing as well
of don't do more than you have to
so I want to show a few visualization
things in this as well so here's a and
I'll get this running because it takes a
few seconds and I haven't got the timing
on this so you'll have to watch how long
this takes I've got a dataset Spath
million data points and I'm I'm stuck in
one function here so I can't improve the
the details of that but it takes a while
to generate this graphic object with
half a million data points on now I
don't know what screen resolution I'm on
here but that image is probably about
500 pixels wide so printing 500 thousand
base points is just a complete waste I
can't see the data points there's ten
points on top of each other for every
pixel and so that would be more than you
have to if you use some of the options
like max plot points Mathematica can
intelligently down-south alas and we get
an almost identical picture using only
the number of pixels that you can see
anyway and it does a reason the
intelligent job that if you've got a
narrow spike in there it tries to detect
where to down sample apps you don't kind
of just jump by the side of it
and it's also worth bearing in mind that
sometimes automation is your enemy in
Mathematica for performance because it
finds to be all these clever things that
you can intelligently avoid sometimes it
really is your friend so when one of the
subjects of plot points one thing to
realize that especially for those of you
who've been using for a long time since
about version six we've bought in this
idea of recursion control that's a much
smarter way of improving the look of a
plot than turning up the number of plot
points so I plot this with a grid of 150
by hundred and fifty points and we've
got a two megabyte graphic and it took a
second also to produce this version here
has a plot point setting of 10 which is
hopelessly inadequate but it's got a
nice high max recursion and we've
actually got a better plot in half the
memory and about half the time
and you can only really understand
what's going on when you start telling
the mesh on and so if I turn that on to
mush goes to all you will see there is
this fine mesh over the whole thing but
the basic graphic has wasted no time
sampling all this oaring stuff around
it's taken it's ten sample points
concluded that it's boring and it's
concentrated all of its effort in the
area that we that we missed out on any
other
so sometimes smartness Trump's detail
when it comes to performance if it's the
right kind of smartness in Mathematica
and of course one of the times you
really care about performance is when
you want interactivity so there's a
special little detail here I'm going to
show you for interactivity now faster
does this automatically to some extent
but you should be aware of the control
for this that when you've got something
that slow to plot and the vitamins e to
functions not totally trivial sometimes
the refresh rate could be too slow we
have this thing called controller active
that says okay the number of points
you're going to take it's going to be 10
if I'm interacting with you 20 if you're
I'm not and they were curtain is going
to be a minimal recursion if I'm
interacting and some if I'm not and that
means that I can get this rather rubbish
but very fast plots what I'm sliding the
slider around and when I let go then it
fills in some detail which takes a
couple of seconds and we get the
beautiful version so as I say we have
most of the visualizations have this
performance goal goes to automatic that
tries to do a bit of that but if you
really want to kind of not have totally
rubbish plots when you're sliding it
around or all you really want to turn up
the accuracy but turn it down in
interactivity then control active is is
the thing you need to know about
okay so let's go out go away from
building things think just about coding
one of the tools that I consider quite
useful whenever you start being serious
is the wulfing workbench notebooks great
for experimenting when you got up when
you've got a big block of code or when
you really care about the details then
it's better to be well organized and
workbench helps you be better organized
which is a good start but it also comes
with a debugger which is better than the
debugger in the front end and a profiler
which is not available in the the
Mathematica front-end and so if I run
this example here anyone who did
elementary coding will spots that I'm
using double recursion which is an
appalling way to be efficient and so
this Fibonacci function of 35 you can
see is taking an age to to calculate and
find you got there 15 seconds so that's
no good at all and if you didn't know
about recursion then you might be
staring at us thinking well what have I
done wrong it's pretty simple code so I
I popped that over into workbench I'm
sorry there's fonts a bit small but I
don't have to zoom workbench but I've
got the code at the top here exactly the
same and I think I already have this
launched in debug mode and you get this
new profile command and I'm going to run
25 so a slightly smaller problem with
the profiler and what that does is it's
running the code but it's doing
accounting as it goes and it's looking
at what bits of code executed and we get
this little report back and you can read
it you'll see that the vast majority of
time was the main call and you could see
where the big step wise was when on most
of the time seem to go on these two sub
steps not very much time on the actual
arithmetic but the real killer here is
that this function got called to 75,000
times this double recursion caused it to
keep going up and down and up and down
this tree of possibilities and it I
wouldn't say it's frequent but it is not
uncommon that I have been confused by
code and run this and being totally
surprised by the values to get out of
the report and then you spot some little
mistake you've made it's causing
something to go into some horrendous
loop that you weren't expecting and
usually when you get a huge delay and
you're not doing something terribly
complicated then there's some weirdness
that you need to understand below sir
and sticking in print statements
everyone so the first step for debugging
is not necessary very useful and these
kind of thing can give you real insight
ok so then next thing is if you can do
things more than one at a time do the
more than one @ sign now there's some
some good news and some bad news here
the good news is some of this is
automatic and if I do something like
this I'm going to make some data and do
a whole bunch of determinant operations
so I mean a loop here just doing Det of
the data went over and over and over
again things that are numerical library
based on the whole in Mathematica
automatically parallel lives so if I go
into my activity monitor here again
rather small font but I'll read it to
you here Wolfram kernel 400% I've got a
quad-core machine and all four CPUs are
busy doing determinants for me so I
can't really squeeze any more out of out
of my computer than then it's getting so
things like stats anything with with
built-in functions on numerical lists
and matrices tends to do quite well at
that but the bad news is there's all
kinds of things that won't paralyze well
so here I'm doing a similar infinite
loop
expanding some polynomial to make some
big polynomial and if I go back to
Activity Monitor and wait for to settle
then we've got whorfin kernel 100% I've
got one CPU working like crazy and three
twiddling their thumbs waiting for some
work to do so as we go into a more sort
of multi-core well that's getting to be
a bigger and bigger deal that you're
typically for most Mathematica code only
using one CPU even though you've got
this lovely computer you bought with
four right CPUs on board so we do
provide user level parallelization for
that it's a fairly small now set of
commands like parallel table parallel
map parallel thigh parallel evaluate
that allow you to send a job to to
multiple kernel so here if I do this
simple table of time ality testing on
some list of numbers you can see it
takes six and a half seconds but I'm not
gonna fire up for additional slave
mathematical that take instructions from
the mathematical we're looking at and
when I do parallel table so the same
thing except I'm using
the parallel version of table it now
distributes those into four chunks to
each CPU and all four being run at the
same time and then they pull back in
together and we get no not such good one
sometimes you can get very close to
linear improvements if four times faster
for quad-core uh no actually so I'm
doing the arithmetic along that is about
four times faster yeah okay but one
thing to bear in mind and I get this
quite often is people say oh I did
parallel table of this or parallel map
and it was slower it's not always a good
thing and and we haven't solved the
problem of automating that question of
when yet so and here's an example this
I'm doing a bunch of transposes and then
a parallel version of it and you'll see
it's got 20 times slower by paralyzing
and the reason is here I've got a very
simple operation but I've got a large
blob of data to hand over to the slaves
to say do something simple on and then a
large set of answers to get back so
there's dominated by the communication
time so it's like me asking you to do
two plus two for me by the time I've
asked you the question I could have just
done it myself
so there's a sort of a quick checklist
here to think about that if your
questions are independent so you know
the analogy I always give is I can't
paralyze building a skyscraper and
saying you work on the second floor
while you work on first floor because
you can't start on the second floor
until the first balls there they're
dependent tasks and so that's terrible
for parallelization if the question and
answer were small compared to the time
it takes to do them that's a good thing
so if the competition is expensive but
but the set up is relatively simple and
independent then that's great time to
paralyze if it's the opposite answers
then it's not going to help and we do
have a CUDA link but that's the kind of
extreme version they've got to be
completely independent and completely
trivial and it's completely hard work to
you so I don't typically recommend it
but you should know it's there in case
it really matters to you to get that
extra performance okay so another key
thing is about not wasting time ian's do
things only once if you can and the key
paradigm this idiom to remember here is
this pattern here of saying function
definition is the function of the thing
equal to and then do whatever it does
and what that does is when you call this
function it works out the right-hand
side and then it stores the value next
time you call it it it won't have to do
the computation it all just remembered
the value now your trading performance
here for use of memory and so you again
it's a trade off if you're if you're
going to do if your parameter space is
huge and the chances of you asking the
same thing twice as small you're just
wasting memory here and you're and
running out of memory is just as bad for
performance if you've got something that
you're quite to hit the same parameters
again bit of memories well-spent and it
totally rescues my Fibonacci example now
that if I do my 35 with this with this
version we won't bring the intermediate
values then it's now trivially fast
because we prevented that up and down
recursion by remembering it there's a
counterpoint though about not wasting
memory is forget things that you don't
need and here's the key one that a lot
of people don't know about when I do a
computation and I say something like
beta equals say you know what if we did
before some random rules of of let's say
1000 of those then I've stored that in
data and then we come along and we say
clear data and we think we're gonna get
the memory back
well we've cleared data and we've
recovered that bit of memory but we've
missed this in 55 because the out 55 the
percent numbers still remember the
values so we can still refer things by
percent and percent 55 at 7 very
convenient but but it's still using up
the memory so when you're doing things
with large data sets first thing I do is
dollar history length equals zero tells
it don't remember any of these percent
numbers or if you want the convenience
to history length equals two or three or
something so you can say last answer for
you you want remembering them in
perpetuity through the session and
certainly when you're doing things like
importing a gigabytes of data you don't
realize you've actually imported it
twice effectively we've got two copies
of it if you don't if you're keeping
history
since we're short on time I'm gonna skip
this one this is a little bit
complicated but although quite a pod let
me tell you something about dynamic
because this is a one that's a very few
people know about dynamics for things
like manipulate so that so you can have
sliders and update pictures very popular
and we just make some round of data here
and have a manipulate and what it's got
is I've got a graphic where I've got a
point
being mapped over that data and then
I've got a big red point at at a
particular position and as I slide the
slider we're gonna get you can see here
nope can't see anything there we go
we're getting a refresh rate of one a
second pretty poor the reason is that
mini plate makes this whole graphic
dynamic so every time T changes whole
graphic says ah I've changed I need to
refresh and so we redraw all 10,000
points every time we slide the slider
but we know that most of the points
aren't changing and so we need to
communicate that down to the manipulate
and the way to do that is you wrap the
part that's changing in an additional
layer of dynamic and the way dynamic
works is it says if if this dynamic here
the one I've selected has highlighted
that bits now considered dealt with and
so when the outer dynamic the
manipulator has looks at its graphic it
sees nothing that's changed it hasn't
already been dealt with and so now when
I do that only the red point is being
refreshed and we get a reasonable
performance of whatever that is ten
frames a second so finding the bits of
change wrap them in an extra layer of
dynamic it usually doesn't do any harm
so it's worth just experimenting and can
really speed up things that don't need
to be refreshed here's a killer I
definitely need to cover which is
particularly if if you're in a kind of
procedural mindset a lot of people
accumulate data in the most horrible way
for Mathematica they say here's an empty
basket to put the data in I'm gonna
build a loop and every time I do
something I calculate some results I'm
going to append it to that list I'll
stick one on the end and I stick another
one on the end and so on and we'll do
that 40,000 times the problem with this
is that because of the immutable object
that when I add an element in the
well they actually do have to do is
create a new version of it when I copy
the entire list over with the extra
element on the end which is trivial at
the beginning so it doesn't matter if
you've got if you're collecting 20 30
data points if you guys me 40,000 by the
end it's like 39,000 data points have to
be copied over add another 130 9001
copied over and it starts getting slower
and slower so the main the kind of
fastest solution to that is this so in
reap construct where instead of a
pending it to a list I so it into this
sort of mythical Mathematica ether I do
all my computations sewing these things
out and then reap at the end that's
wrapped the whole conversation comes
along and collects them together and
constructs a data object once not 40,000
times and so if I run that now you can
see it's an its recently performance and
I have to say I find it rather an ugly
construct I find it all very confusing
think about souls and reaps and you have
to make sure you take the right part of
the reaped object so there is a an
in-between which is that the new
Association objects in Mathematica which
is main values sort of key value pairs
that doesn't require fresh coffee it's
very fast for writing an update for
changing elements and for appending and
so we get something actually is
reasonably performant there I have to
create a key so I've put a key value on
for each one the first element is called
one and so on
but that's the reasonably performant
because of this internal structure of
Association it's sort of one of the key
performance benefits of Association that
is still faster in in data set than it
is in lists I think even overwrites
causes a significant refresh of list
whereas data set herbs are so not they
said Association is basically a set of
pointers and so you only ever updating
what fits pointed to so if you're if
you're using a big data set as a kind of
state maintenance you're better usually
better off with a Association than with
lists
definitely don't use a pin to to
accumulate Victor say so it's like the
mortal sin of Luke programming in
Mathematica so there's one for others
I'll show you the download link in a
moment let me just sum up since I've
completely run out of time and say
here's the sort of meta points think
about whether you're being more accurate
than the answer you care about don't
reimplemented
the huge documentation looking for the
function that's just right for what
you're doing is well spent time rather
than spending the time coding something
yourself and then think about doing
things once compiled in parallel if
possible but when I saw which I didn't
get to talk about is experiment there
isn't really a definite because
sometimes there's some little bit of
magic that we've hidden inside some
function that you wouldn't expect it to
be faster but because somebody had some
clever idea about that algorithm it just
is magically faster and this changes
from version to version so it's worth
doing a little bit of experimenting
because sometimes you're taking by
surprise by things just being faster
than they should be because of some
hidden magic